THE DAY IN THE LAST TEN, LOSING
328 TODAY.
TONIGHT CORRESPONDENT
KEVIN CORKE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
ON THE SHORT-TERM CONSEQUENCES
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TRADE
POLICY.
>> Reporter: AND ANNOUNCING
THE COMPANY WHICH OF THE
PRODUCTION OF SOME OF ITS
THE BRAKES ON A KEY WHITE HOUSE
TARIFFS SAVES AMERICAN JOBS.
TARIFFS OF 25% ON STEEL AND 10%
CHARGING IMPORT DUTIES ON A
RANGE OF U.S. PRODUCTS INCLUDING
MOTORCYCLES AND IN HARLEY'S
CASE, THAT MEANT RAISING OF A
TARIFF ON IMPORTED HARLEYS.
THE COMPANY SUGGESTED THIS
WASN'T AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF AN AGGRESSIVE TRADE POLICY BY
THE WHITE HOUSE, CALLING ITS
DECISION THE ONLY SUSTAINABLE
OPTION TO MAKE ITS MOTORCYCLES
ACCESSIBLE TO CUSTOMERS IN THE
BLAME FOR THE TARIFF DISPUTES
SQUARELY AT THE FEET OF THE E.U.
>> THINK EUROPEAN UNION IS
REPEATEDLY IN UNFAIR TRADE
PRACTICES, AND THE PRESIDENT IS
SAYING, ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> SANDERS 'HAS, AS REFLECTED IN
AGGRESSIVE POSTURE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WILBUR ROSS THAT THE DAYS OF
AND PROPOSED INVESTMENT
RESTRICTIONS WILL TARGET ALL
COUNTRIES THAT ARE TRYING TO
STEAL OUR TECHNOLOGY.
THEY ARE NOT SO VEILED REFERENCE
TO CHINA.
INDUSTRY NEXT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY
RATTLING 20% IMPORT FEE.
>> IN THE SHORT TERM, IT'S NOT
GOOD FOR TRUNK.
THE MARKETS DON'T LIKE TARIFFS.
AT THE MARKET LOVES TRUMP BUT
THEY DON'T LIKE TARIFFS.
WE ARE SEEING AN IMMEDIATE
NEGATIVE REACTION.
>> THE U.S. IS SET TO HIT CHINA